[Music]
india's festive season is underway as
millions of people gather for religious
festivals
often without any protective measures
against covet 19.
health experts fear these mass
gatherings could turn into super
spreader events
i can find many people are moving
without the mask they are not
maintaining the social distancing i am
feeling happy though the crowd is
excessive i am sweating like hell but
still i am enjoying it
[Music]
same time last year infection numbers
spiked with hundreds of thousands of new
cases each day
i'm ben fazoulen nice to have you along
anyone who's been to india knows
festivals mean masses of people and with
it a risk of infections spreading
after a brutal second wave and a bumpy
vaccination roll out close to a third of
the population is now fully vaccinated
that's enough for many in india to join
in the festivities
[Music]
the victory of good over evil
that is one of the key themes around the
hindu festivals of the shera and diwali
[Music]
and these delhi residents are clamoring
to leave the evil of the coronavirus
behind
celebrations are meant to be low-key
this is the only traditional theshara
performance allowed in the capital this
year
and the audience is strictly limited
but that isn't holding these crowds back
nor are people shying away from busy
festive markets
restrictions in shopping districts have
been lifted completely
and covert appropriate behavior isn't
being enforced
for many here their confidence stems
from the vaccine
i've gotten my second dose so now i feel
a lot more comfortable about being in
public places
cases are low right now so our hopes are
high and vaccinations are going well
for the lucky few who have been allowed
into performances like this one
it is the closest they felt to normalcy
since the pandemic began
i think more excited than scared because
it's been such a long long time that
we've been able to do anything like this
i miss the crowds
the food stalls and the swings but i'm
still really glad we got to attend this
the head of the delhi government also
reinforced a message of hope
i pray that we defeat the demon of the
karuna virus
that god keeps all of you healthy and
free of
disease lord rama kills the demon king
ravan
the euphoric crowds momentarily forget
about the pandem
but it may yet be a long wait till the
threat of the coronavirus 2 goes up in
flames
[Applause]
rajiv tascopter joins us now he heads
the center for social medicine and
community health at jnu in delhi nice to
have you on the show again
as we saw there celebrations underway
and
people having a great time but tell me
what what do you think only around 30
percent fully vaccinated how risky is
that for these people
hello ben
um
the visuals of the durga puja that we
saw
particularly if you talk of west bengal
which has certainly witnessed a rise in
cases
the the outcome of that surge would
depend on an interplay of two things
uh these the zero prevalence the zero
positivity in west bengal by the last
fourth national serial survey
which is relatively low at about 61
and coverage with two vaccines which is
also relatively low at about 27
so a state like west bengal with both
the parameters being low would certainly
be at additional risk what could perhaps
be protective and that's something we
would be able to gauge full in the
coming weeks
is how much protection a single dose of
vaccine is according because west bengal
has uh about 72 coverage with a single
dose
and that would really um
entail what proportion would actually
fall sick
from the covid and how much this current
surge would last
so where would you put the likelihood of
another surge of cases then
given the very high levels of zero
positivity
in most indian states and in fact the
more recent ones which have come out in
the last two weeks state-specific ones
actually show that zero protection is
pretty high as a combination of
both vaccination as well as disease
both clinical disease and asymptomatic
disease so that's protective uh
presently but should there be a new
variant or particularly a new highly
transmissible variant that could
certainly change the complexion of the
game
and and what role might natural immunity
play now that so many indians have
caught the coronavirus
well cases are currently at a low of
about 12
000 to 13 000.
the deaths may seem a bit
disproportionately high
uh compared to the new cases but that's
because several states have uh have
reviewed the data reconciled the death
date and therefore there have been some
new death
notifications but they are not new
deaths uh so to say
so therefore at present it's seemingly a
comfortable situation uh but that that
owes a lot to the to the high zero
positivity and we heard in that report
uh
a confident young man saying that lots
of people have now been vaccinated i
mean
we're talking about what you said 27 30
um and india recently administering its
one billionth coronavirus jab i mean are
people getting overconfident
um the one million jab is certainly a
very creditable
feat
i think what we need to be worried about
is roughly half a dozen to eight states
which are below the national average
these are very large states states with
very large populations
one of one of the largest states uttar
pradesh for example has
uh 20 percent of the population covered
with two doses a state with high
incidence maharashtra which which has
mumbai
city in it uh has a coverage
of
32 with two vaccines
so so these are the states that we need
to look out for on the other hand the
states which have really had high
coverage above 50
and nearly 60 percent in some of the
smaller states so it's a very mixed
picture we really need to keep a look
out for some of these very large states
rajib one thing that india hasn't been
battling is uh vaccine hesitancy a lot
of countries are struggling with that
why is india doing so well in in getting
people to actually take the vaccine
we need to give credit to
perhaps two things
one certainly
the
the forthright conviction of the present
government
in putting its full weight uh in the
vaccination program
uh
and but secondly what we also need to
pay tribute to is a systematic
strengthening of the immunization
program in the context of
polio eradication and this current phase
of strengthening or systematically
strengthening has been going on for last
two decades
once the 2000 milestone for polio
eradication was missed
so the current vaccination has
the current campaign has come on very
strong fundamentals and that's what is
really paying uh paying dividends it
isn't that there haven't been cases of
hesitancy but the campaign has also been
proactive about it but uh but we
certainly need to recognize the strong
fundamentals
project
from jnu thank you very much for being
on the show today
thank you
another viewer question now from derek
williams and this time a question on the
covert 19 vaccine
why do i need a kovit covit-19 vaccine
if it doesn't prevent me from catching
the disease
i think that this question more than any
other illustrates how governments and
healthcare authorities have really
struggled with messaging in this
pandemic um to answer it let's go back
over some of the stuff that they could
have probably communicated better
first i think
is the fact that despite really great
efficacy numbers from clinical trials
the vaccines that we have are not
perfect silver bullets and we should
never have expected them to be what they
have so far proved to provide
is some very effective short-term
protection from serious illness and
death
caused by covid um it would be great
if that protection were indefinite but
but there are indications that it might
be less long-term
than we'd hoped
one recent model based study that's
gotten some attention
posits that if sars cov2 becomes endemic
then reinfection in people who got it
once
could on average occur again in just 16
months now if correct
that obviously has implications for
durability of immune response in
vaccinated people as well
but that's just one prediction and over
the course of this pandemic
it feels like those have proven wrong a
lot more often than they've proven right
so
i would encourage people to focus more
on what we really do
know now um
like the crystal clear data-based
statistics published by the cdc in the
u.s
they showed that although vaccines
haven't prevented covid19 or it's spread
completely there
unvaccinated people are still five times
more likely to test positive for the
disease
than vaccinated people are and
more importantly unvaccinated people are
10 times more likely to end up in the
hospital and 10 times more likely to die
so
does being vaccinated guarantee you
won't get coveted 19 or or maybe even
die from it no
but for at least a while maybe a long
while
vaccines certainly do
stack the deck a lot more in your favor
and you saw the celebrations from india
earlier
let's leave you with preparations for
sunday's day of the dead parade in
mexico city it was cancelled last year
due to the pandemic
authorities only gave the go ahead at
short notice artisans rushing to put
together their floats and costumes and
masks the parade is not an ancient
tradition it was actually inspired by
the 2015 james bond movie spectre the
ideas caught on last time around three
million people took part
i'm ben fazel and thanks for joining us
on another coconutting special
[Music]